aquí en kiev la capital ucraniana
igorreiren están en medio de la
oscuridad en su casa como estaba
previsto se ha cortado de la
electricidad en su barrio del norte de
la ciudad en un intento porno
sobrecargar la red eléctrica tenemos
horarios de cortes que ahora son válidos
todo el tiempo aquí puede ver El pequeño
apagón de hoy
son muchos los ucranianos que están
viviendo una situación similar a la de
este matrimonio en medio de la oleada de
ataques rusos sobre la infraestructura
energética ucraniana que ya inhabilitado
el 40% de su red desde el 10 de octubre
si no fuera por la guerra habría vivido
a la luz de las velas como un romance en
una vida primitiva Cuando una persona se
levanta con el sol y se acuesta con el
sol
un problema que no se limita la capital
del país otras regiones como gerson
citomire harkie o chernihiv también
están sufriendo estos estragos o
crenergó la empresa Estatal y operadora
eléctrica advirtió que se espera más
ataque apagones con al menos 4 millones
y medio de ucranianos sin electricidad y
el invierno cada vez más cerca
la red eléctrica del país sigue sin
poder reanudar su pleno funcionamiento
tras los atentados terroristas de Rusia
en algunas regiones tenemos que inducir
apagones para evitar la sobrecarga de la
infraestructura de alta tensión desde
que el alcalde instó a los ciudadanos a
trasladarse a domicilios de amigos o
familiares en el peor de los casos ya
acusó al presidente Vladimir Putin de
atacar directamente a los civiles
Putin no nos necesita a los ucranianos
su objetivo es que muramos que nos
congelemos o que huyamos de nuestra
tierra para que él pueda tenerla Y es
que las autoridades ucranianas no
descartan ningún escenario con el apagón
total y el corte por completo del
suministro de agua en kiev como una
posibilidad